رونالدو قلت رايح وقلت المبلغ تمام ميسي
قلت رايح ولسه شبه مؤكد بنزيما رايح ولا
مش رايح بنزيما دن نعم خلاص بس ما فيش عقد
في جيب المره دي اه بس
اقدر اقول ان الصفقه خلاص تمت طبعا حصل
تاخير يومين ثلاثه في الفتره دي كما تقول
الصحافه المدريديه المقربه من ريال مدريد
ان بيريز كان بيبحث عن البديل وخلينا نقول
ان بنزيما من اوفى الاوفياء ريال مدريد
وفي نقطه كمان ربما البعض لا يعلمها ان
بيريز يعشق هذا اللاعب تحديدا في تاريخ
ريال مدريد وفي تاريخ اداره بيريز
بالمناسبه بيريز يساوي رؤساء دول في
مكانته وهيبته يعني اللاعب الوحيد اللي
ذهاب له للبيت لليوم في فرنسا ليتفاوض
معاها هو كريم بنزيما ابدا لم يفعلها مع
اي لاعب وضل طوال مسيره كريم بنزيما يدع
مه بشكل غير عادي طوال الوقت حتى في الوقت
اللي كان
ضده وفرنسا ومشكله المنتخب وكذا كان دائما
داعم لكريم بنزيما
طيب استاذ محمد ما الذي تتوقعه او ما هو
الشيء الذي سيقدمه بنزيما في حال تاكد
ظهور ذهابه الى الاتحاد لنادي الاتحاد
وايضا ما الذي سيقدم للدوري السعودي بعد
رونالدو صحيح اصبحت المعادله هي يعني
خلينا نقول خلال ايام تكتمل رونالدو مع
الهلال وميسي
رونالدو النصر مع النصر
اعتقد عايزين ميسي كمان وهو وميسي طبعا
وكريم بنزيما مع الاتحاد اكبر ثلاث انديه
واعتقد الكره العالميه ستبقى ستكون في
السعوديه يعني بعد ذلك
ماذا سيقدم انا ظني انه هو عمره 35 ولكن
لازال فت جدا وهداف يعني هداف بالمعنى
الحرف لكلمه هداف يستطيع انه يخلص الكثير
من المباريات وكما قلنا من قبل نجوم بهذا
الوزن نقوم بهذه الشعبيه يتجاوز وجودهم
مساله كره القدم
ومساله تسويقيه في ملف
للسعوديه لكاس العالم يعني كما نقول يعني
لم لم يصبح حقيقه سيكون سفراء ولكن في
الطريق سيكونوا سفراء له لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات